how's it goin breasts - welcome to
another spooky episode of outlast all
right
Oh more sewer
yeah that's Oh hi friend
how are you oh no it's the guy who
wanted to kiss oh that's so sad you are
there you go I'm so sorry okay we're not
going there
we're not going there we're not going
there ah what do you want from the same
[ __ ] gay man huh [ __ ] game
don't you dare jump-scare i played
enough horror games should know where
this [ __ ] is going
what Oh Oh
what I can't hear you
[Music]
shut up
god you're a million bad ear every dates
that guy if you know what I mean this is
a regular yard just get oh [ __ ] is that
crazy preach oh hey alright I can
totally the same you you know it's not
really the doctors did you do it right
darn turkey died before he even started
working here what kind of experiments
does a dead doctor perform on living
patients well at least you're not naked
I trust anyone and not did naked in this
game the Leicester clothes the more the
hose wait what now a key fuse
so I don't know why they don't subtitle
because I have subtitle all right is he
still there
what is this batteries and the man has
gone to the barn in Bournemouth can we
go through here you know we can't it
looks like we're supposed to be in here
I don't know what you want from me if
you want the Twix you don't have it
sorry I just I don't know I figured
you'd be happy by the thought of it Winx
sponsor not really but still it could be
if you think about it really hard
Twix to send me tweaks actually I'm not
a big fan er why is it red here they're
making tomato soup oh I get it
now it makes sense yeah well follow the
red they said so we're gonna go okay
we're going here wait go gosh darn it
that door is closed isn't it so they
have [ __ ] at the club huh what that
is cuckoo there's gonna be some weird
they said sexual activities so I'm
expecting some awesome [ __ ] what were
you doing huh it's always the eyebrow
guy who puts the trash here
but that's how I take showers don't
judge okay what is that the [ __ ] is that
that's the spirit leg
what the [ __ ]
what is that
I think that sword is close they want us
to go here I don't trust this
alone
okay well this one oh [ __ ] all a duel it
off king kelana cough cough Alana binky
Barnett oh really do we lead off this
way gasp damn it so it's like that
Jesus guys this gave me that page I
don't even know what I'm doing but I'm
Navin a is this a door oh you just had
to - yeah hey I kissed you I kissed you
how dare you dance in front of me oh I'm
I'm better at you well I'm better than
you
yeah that's right yeah that's right you
think you're good I'm telling this I'm
filming it yeah [ __ ] okay not there
[Music]
great
[Applause]
I don't oh sure plenty more no teddy now
I mean okay go up go up why can't you go
on there we go
oh thank heavens what
hi-yah what I thought was that are you
lit enough to see what this game is
going
oh geez oh geez oh geez
cuz [ __ ] Christ
[Applause]
hello fit buyer imma imma imma I'm just
a guy I'm not looking to die I just want
to get high
love and friendship nothing else nothing
else okay looks like we can go here what
is this place I just wanted to take a
shower man oh great
come on [ __ ] me
what is it going on here I heard about
pariahs that will eat your balls I think
this is edge
he's telling me I can't go up from that
stupid [ __ ] life
[Music]
it's gonna be okay you're being too
scared
geez don't be a [ __ ] it's okay you can
be if you're a can't get it because no
oh I can just go up there oh my [ __ ]
god why did I not see that sayonara
amigo just kidding you're not my [ __ ]
Oh jumping later no that was easy
what did I not do that laughs oh that
music is scaring me a little bit less
what do you want today huh or you're
just covering your ugly face well that's
understandable
is it chasing me oh I do not like this
oh hello just I was going this way
I would if I could whoa but I got an
idiot whoa okay everything went better
than Jesus
just kidding that's impossible
[Music]
okay all I wanted was to make youtube
videos what's your story don't be
offensive ain't many wars but I wanted
to nominate a war so far in this game
anyone I met with a penis have not been
Pleasant it kind of is like a real life
I don't even want to think about what a
family with a penis is like but I guess
I just said you're thinking about it too
now you're welcome okay let's not waste
too much batteries
I don't really know about this hello
that's everything okay I'm a doctor
just kidding I'm not but that wasn't
even a joke okay what's that noise
seriously oh geez
okay whoa whoa I could have been [ __ ]
fried like potatoes a.m. follow the
blood they said it will be fine
oh jeez this is where we started isn't
it yeah that's where we fell down oh
dang I don't want to go to the main wad
see the yelling [ __ ]
reach the ground floor on the main ward
yeah that's easy okay
we just have to use our wits and
handsomeness and swagalicious clothing
and we'll be fine
okay what are you what are you what I
what I what I would oh yes of course
ghetto but but odd weights more than
Oprah I'm so sorry Oprah if you're
watching this it's nothing ah get away
what do you want from me why are you so
heavy
I mean box whatever you're not really a
box are you doesn't matter
I'll see you later bent
oh you how do you get here seriously hey
hey hey it's gonna be okay
don't you die on me okay I'll see you
later skater a either hater Allen
potater do you want me to close the door
doesn't matter what do you want now tell
me what you want but you're a little bit
that's not the right song okay there's a
lot of blood again which it's usually
not a good thing but hey at least I'm
not Michael Jackson I don't know why I
just wanted to be optimistic about
thing not going there what's going on
watch it Oh Oh do you think it I don't
think you need what's you're sorry
oh [ __ ] stop I don't like this
what is that the camera I want dad to
what am I supposed to do here why am I
doing this why am I doing this this is a
[ __ ] suicide
okay that's okay
hey it's you Hey whoa that's a good
escape let's check here first okay well
it looks like we're gonna have to go
here oh hell no what is up with this
place I am NOT cool with this place nah
oh hello batteries and the mornings
gonna Shh shut up oh geez
hey I want to cheat that too come on
not cool okay let's just this it's not
hello come on not so confident so now
are you Oh Joe whoa bro what happened to
you
can I open these maybe I shouldn't
nothing can be too alive except if it's
dead I guess but I feel like I should
look for something here oh I can go up
here maybe oh oh oh snappy snow on my
new shoes except I don't have any dishes
that's the genius part about it hello
calm down calm down
you sold me out Magnus
push push internal Emmet walk along the
razor's head it's big it's big it's big
no dude flank I'm not to find a flag not
a fan of flanking either
let's [ __ ] still fight I mean why
would you do that [ __ ] oh push it to the
limit
yeah [ __ ] taxes well the same page bro
we're on the same page oh Jesus Christ
push it to the limit why does it have to
be so happy ok ok it's good
oh no I don't know I did not cheat on
your girlfriend she cheated was it ma'am
don't take on this I'm a Big Mac oh hey
how you doin
all right brother really hope you
enjoyed this episode sorry for the
cliffhanger ending but it was extra long
so leave a like if you enjoyed that hit
subscribe to become a road today
I'll see in the next one if you dare
I'm ready got a pair